[Música]
bienvenidos a el ascendido en esta
edición desde lima perú hoy hablaremos
sobre las consecuencias del derrame de
alrededor de 12.000 barriles de petróleo
de la transnacional española repsol en
la costa peruana se cumplieron cuatro
meses de lo que ha sido denominado uno
de los peores desastres ambientales
ocurridos en el litoral peruano las
autoridades de este país calculan que la
tragedia ambiental impactó a más de 15
mil hectáreas que involucra a playas y
áreas naturales protegidas así como la
fauna aniquilando a cientos de especies
muchos expertos consideran que los
efectos del hidrocarburo durarán por lo
menos 10 años el daño de repsol también
cobró un alto costo social miles de
pescadores sus familias así como
comerciantes resultaron perjudicados
ellos viven un drama que jamás se
imaginaron
[Música]
el 15 de enero el buque italiano madre
de origen descargaba petróleo a las
tuberías submarinas de repsol la
transnacional española dijo que un
oleaje anómalo originó una fuga de 25
litros de hidrocarburo luego señaló que
eran 6.000 barriles pero las autoridades
peruanas revelaron que se trataba en
realidad de 11 mil 900 barriles de crudo
organismos estatales precisan que 15 mil
845 hectáreas fueron dañadas en su
ventanilla en la provincia del callao
hasta la provincia de huaral al norte de
lima 46 playas quedaron potencialmente
afectadas dos áreas naturales protegidas
se encuentran en situación crítica y
centenares de especímenes murieron o
quedaron con secuelas de la
contaminación la afectación se ha visto
muy evidente al registrar a la fecha
555 aves muertas de 10 especies entre
cormoranes piqueros pingüinos one ice
y además se ha registrado más de 80 aves
9393 sabes que hemos podido rescatar
aves que se encontraban convalecientes y
manchadas de petróleo
debilitadas repsol ha pagado multas al
estado peruano por 615 mil dólares y ha
judicial izado una sanción por más de
dos millones de dólares la compañía
también fue criticada por mezclar arena
contaminada de petróleo con arena
intacta como metodología de limpieza
repsol rechaza las acusaciones y afirma
que realizó más de 1400 muestreo ofició
químicos en suelo y en el mar
a través de un comunicado de la compañía
petrolera española anunció que culminó
la limpieza de 28 playas y que éstas se
encuentran limpias por su parte la
defensoría del pueblo advierte que no ha
sido oficialmente declarada limpia ni
una playa pero la contaminación también
dejó consecuencias sociales miles de
pescadores artesanales se quedaron sin
empleo
el petróleo derramado perjudicó el
trabajo de los hombres de marc y desde
el 22 de enero cuando el gobierno de
pedro castillo declaró el estado de
emergencia no pueden salir a pescar para
conseguir el sustento para sus hogares a
todos nosotros pescadores artesanales
nos ha afectado en uno de un tema es
económico y social y no solamente a
nosotros sino a la gran mayoría de
pescadores artesanales que somos no
tenemos versiones exactas pero puede
pueden ser como 15.000 pescadores
artesanales afectados
porque nosotros contamos mucho cuenta
solamente con los que están afiliados en
asociaciones pero hay muchos que no son
afiliados son independientes y los
independientes son muchos
el derrame ocasionado por repsol se
produjo en verano la mejor época de
ganancias en que pescadores y
comerciantes aprovechan para guardar
dinero para la temporada baja de
invierno cientos de restaurantes que
trabajan con pescado reportan cuantiosas
pérdidas muchos de ellos cerraron yo
creo que ha sido más de un 70 por ciento
de verdad porque hay mucha gente como
ustedes que ya no vine a trabajar
hay muchos restaurantes también que han
sido muy afectados y si por lo menos 70%
y eso no solamente que dijo de trabajar
yo o deje de trabajar mi
ayudante atrás de y hay una familia
atrás de la otra persona y familia
entonces esto es como una cadena para
compensar los daños sociales repsol
entregó a más de 5 mil 500 damnificados
empadronados 2 bonos por más de 1600
dólares y vales de alimentos por más de
260 dólares pero la defensoría del
pueblo advierte que son muchos más los
ciudadanos que quedaron vulnerables
serían más de 15 mil personas las
afectadas ahora estamos hablando de
afectaciones a por ejemplo pescadores no
que
ciertamente teniendo los pescadores
artesanales que ciertamente teniendo en
el litoral contaminado no pueden
realizar este tipo de labores pero
también se advertía
personas que realizaban actividades como
el
comercio comercio ambulatorio comercio
de restaurantes el futuro legal de la
transnacional española
a la autoridad nacional de protección al
consumidor presentó una demanda judicial
contra repsol por 4.500 millones de
dólares por responsabilidad civil de
riesgo en perjuicio de más de 700.000
personas gracias por acompañarnos en
esta emisión de enlace andino desde lima
perú les invitamos a que nos envíen sus
sugerencias sobre temas que les gustaría
ver en nuestro programa sigan
disfrutando de la programación de france
24 en español y hasta pronto
[Música]